i just finished my round seven game of
the abu dhabi masters tournament
and it was a long one uh it was what
time is it
it's 9 32. the game started at
5 p.m i just got back to my hotel room
so
i'm gonna try and finish this recap
before dinner ends
uh even though it's a really long game
uh i was playing grand master robert
hovan hovannissien
a strong grandmaster
and um
he's actually uh he was part of this
viral moment from the olympiad he was a
player that defeated sam shankland
after this sort of infamous touch move
incident i'm sure a lot of people who
watch chess often on youtube might have
seen this uh this moment
and this was like a big uh victory for
armenia over the us
in the olympiad so it was my mission
this game to get revenge for sam
uh for for losing to robert but uh as
we're gonna see it was a
very hotly contested fight
and i decided this game to stray away
from my typical london opening
i almost always played bishop f4 in this
position
but i opted for a queen's gambit
which i very rarely play although i did
play uh queen's gambit in an earlier
round that kind of transposed him in
english but this is the first time
maybe ever that i'm playing
c4
in this position on move two
and we ended up getting uh queensgam
declined
and uh i was very pleased to see
he played bishop f5 the so-called
positional line
and if you saw
which round was it it was my recap
against rucha pujari
i was actually preparing this line
for her from the white side
so even though i didn't really look at
my prep for this
before the game
i was excited to enter this line i
played queen to f3 bishop g6 takes takes
takes takes and this is a pretty well
known um imbalance end game where
maybe not end game but queenless middle
game where black has a bishop hair and
uh white has some preferable pawn
structure
and
i was inspired by magnus carlsen to play
this line he had a really nice victory
over vladimir kramnik
in
2016 and he used some really cool idea
of playing like knight h4 and then bring
the other knight to the king's side
so that game was fresh in my mind and i
employed
the same sort of idea
but in that game i believe
kramnik played bishop e7
and it went down a different route after
92 bishop before check
uh was the carlson kramnik game
um
or wait
was it
let's just insert this
ah kramnik played knight b6 this this is
a carlson kramnik game um it was
actually a beautiful positional
masterpiece which i don't have time to
get into right now but if people uh
people want to look at that game i will
leave a link to
the lead chess analysis where you can
investigate
uh the analysis further
but instead of bishop e7 my opponent
played bishop to b4
and this is already a new position for
me
and i tried to react naturally i played
king d2
a5 and bishop d3 offering the trade of
bishops trying to fight for this kind of
key f5 square uh nice square in white's
control in front of the double f pawns
uh he plays a4 play rook to c1 the
reason for moving the h rook was i was
envisioning at some point playing b3 and
if the file opens i wanted to ensure my
rook was still on a1
uh he played knight b6 b3 restricting
the knight
but at the same time
this move did give black some potential
on the queen side
where there's lingering tension now
between the pawns
and he didn't relieve the tension
so uh the pawns had just a staring
contest
and i decided to expand on the king side
dreaming of trapping the bishop but of
course he takes
takes and rook a7
and i think this is a nice idea for
black to leave the tension and try and
double up the rooks behind the apon uh
and then later try and open the file
and there is a brief moment where i was
looking at a3 but then i quickly
realized this move doesn't work because
takes
and if takes there's b2 and oh no one of
my rooks so
i didn't play a3 play rook a b1
takes takes and i did concede the a file
but
black can't really make use of it so
much because
i'm controlling the two kind of main
infiltration squares rook a3 doesn't do
much the b-pawn is always defended
so i was still feeling relatively
comfortable here rook 8 9 f5
and for a very brief moment i thought we
might repeat moves like when i played
knight f5 i thought maybe he would play
king
e6 and then i can play
check
king e7 check and this would be
repetition possibly
uh but that didn't happen he played rook
to g8 hitting the g pawn i defend
and then he takes on c3 and plays h5
so the game keeps going uh things have
simplified a bit and i think it's safe
to say we are in the end game h5 was
kind of an annoying move because it
stopped me from playing
of course
discouraged g4 entirely but it also has
the idea of playing king
to
e6
and i should note that if he plays king
e6 too soon i could play knight h6
and uh there's no rook g6 because f5 is
a nice fork
but with the pawn and h5
if we go into the same line king e6986
he would have rook h8 uh just trapping
the knight so i did have to be a bit
careful here played knight g3 hitting
the pawn he defends i play king d3
now one note
uh i kind of realized this during the
game
uh the dgt board was not working uh
because there was an arbiter that came
by at various moments
who would just take a picture of our
scoresheets and then he would walk away
and i presumably he was like manually
entering the moves
uh so
yeah disregard the timestamps here
uh at this point i probably had like 20
25 minutes left i was taking my time
in the middle game and
i think for most the game he was
up maybe 10 to 20 minutes on me
but okay things continue 92
knight c8 this is a very common
positional maneuver the black knight is
happiest on the d6 square to control
some more key center squares i play
knight c3 knight d6
and now i play e4 so deciding to
transform the position i didn't want to
give him time to play f5 and e4 and i
thought e4 is an attempt to
maybe place for some advantage
given that if i can open the e file and
then the black king can maybe be a
target
but as we're gonna see things get really
messy after takes takes takes takes
things get messy after the trades which
might seem a little bit strange but
yeah after rook d8 rook c5 rook 2a2
um i really wasn't sure how to evaluate
what was going on here and i wasn't sure
like who's playing for a win pretty sure
this is the type of position where all
three results are possible
um because black is of course activating
the rook attacking my pawns but i have
some interesting counter play
against black setup especially against
the king on e6 i decided to play a
tricky move here
rook to e1
and i quietly said oh no my pawn but if
he takes a pawn then king f3 and this is
a nice
double attack so
of course he didn't take the pawn he
instead plays rook g8
which
somehow i overlooked but i think this is
a nice move from black to just attack
the pawn again
and the rooks really want to coordinate
on the second ring
and if i play g3 then h pawn hangs and
he defends his h pawn and then g3 is
hanging
so
i took some time here and i played rook
takes h5
allowing the rook to infiltrate and then
king d3 check
forcing the king away from these pawns
and then i play rook to h6
and um
at this point i thought the game was
heading towards the draw because i'm
hitting the pawn on h6
or on on f6
and it's not so easy for black to defend
he could play rook g6 was half expecting
this after which takes takes and rook
team won
i think more pawns would come off the
board and this should be pretty trash
but instead he decided to check on d2
play team e6 and uh yeah the game keeps
going i played i5 here he played king d5
and then i took on f6
now there was one alternative here
um she actually mentioned to me after
the game i had the move rook h8
which i don't think was on my radar but
i should have at least considered this
move because i am threatening maiden one
and it's not so clear
i mean i guess king d6
and then i can check maybe this is a
better line and then if i can win a 7
with check
and then take f6
um yeah maybe this this is an easier way
to simplify
but i took on f6 immediately
allowing rook takes d4
and at this point i was falling below
five minutes
and
i wasn't
wasn't entirely sure how to handle the
position
um because now black is threatening rook
takes h2
and if i take on f7
then what was i scared of oh is it
scared of this move yeah rookie 4 is the
main threat here to to win my rook
um so rook h2 it's a secondary threat
but this is a main threat
uh so i decided to
try and defend everything with rook h1
getting my rook off the file defending
the pawn and even though this looks like
a passive square for the rook i thought
someday i could just sprint the pawn
down the h file
so he plays rook to b2
and at this point
i got really low on time i i thought for
a few minutes here fell below a minute
and i was trying to decide between
uh rook
to d6 to force the trader rooks or rook
takes f7 and allow this and it gets a
little bit murky i decided to play rook
t6
with idea that after takes takes
takes i am down the pawn but my h-pawn
is ready to run
and run it did uh h4
rook b4 king c3 rook a4
uh however unfortunately this position
i think black has everything under
control
and after h5 king e5 h6
black's rook is in time to
come back to the h8 square if i play h7
then there's rook 2 h8
and this point i'm just trying to hold
on for dear life
i played the move rook h5
in hindsight i don't know if i had
anything better
i was dreaming of a scenario where like
black's
king gets stuck on f6
and i do something like this and this
and then black is a little bit paralyzed
here
unfortunately
he has a different idea he plays pawn f6
and the king is ready to walk around to
g4
and unfortunately my king is just a
little bit too far away to stop black's
idea
so i play king d3 he plays king to f4
and after h7 rook h8
there's no stopping king g4
and
at this point i thought i was just gonna
be dead lost
but then i realized
it's not over and i can play the move
king d4 king g4
give up the f pawn
give up the h pawn
i'm currently down three pawns here
but after king b6
it's not so simple for black to win this
uh because this pawn's falling the king
is cut off and once i win b7 i can try
and win c6 and then come back and catch
that pawn
and during the game i i wasn't sure what
the
like true evaluation of the position
should be i mean it really seems like
black should be winning
um but okay the game continued he plays
rook g8
chasing my rook away from the g file
now i can't trade rooks of course in
this position so i give a check king g6
i take
and he plays a very wise move rook d8
ensuring my keen will be cut off
and here i play rook g1
um delaying taking the pawn i wanted to
improve my rook
and it's an interesting idea to just
check from in front of the pawn
and if the king wants to find shelter it
has to go behind the pawn so i thought i
would
provoke the king to be on a slightly
more passive square
and then here we repeated for a little
bit
he brought the king to g5
then he brought the king back to g5 so
already this position we've repeated
twice
i was just hoping we can get one more
occurrence of king g5 rook g1
but let me play king g6
and this position has also been repeated
twice but then he finally plays king f7
so there is no three-fold repetition
and my only chance is to take the pawn
and he plays pawn f5
and now i'm i'm still cut off but i want
to make sure my king is
uh just back uh
towards the promotion square of the pawn
so uh okay he moves up i play rook f1
and now it's very important for me to
stop that pawn from moving
but he found a nice idea here after king
g5 rook g1
king h4
and after rook f1
king g4
rook g1 he puts the king on h3
and then once i play rook f1
he doesn't have to move back with the
king
he plays rook f8
and
even though he
is no longer cutting off the king
his king is perfectly optimized to help
the pawn advance and also to
gain tempo on my rook
and unfortunately i think this is a
losing position for white
um
i mean i
did my best in the game to try and
survive king d4 but after king g2 my
rook just doesn't have a great place to
go the move i want to play is rook f4
but after king g3
defending the rook doesn't work because
of rook e a check and my rook's gonna be
lost king f5 there's rook f8
so
we got to this position i was still
pretty low on time living on increments
i thought until i had one second left
and i played the move rook to e1
uh the idea being i was envisioning
something like f4 rookie 7 and then get
my king
somewhere on the e file but
he didn't even allow that he plays rook
to d8
and now i can't move to the file because
i got skewered had to move to the c file
and then we get what's called the lucina
position
which is a very well known
rook ending
it's uh of course king and rook vs king
rook and pawn
and this is a position that my first
chess coach taught me when i was
about eight or nine years old
and it's a position that
any grandmaster will probably have done
multiple times in their life
the the winning idea for black is to get
the pawn to the second rank which he
eventually did
um
the checks don't really help me that
much
i play king c2
uh gets upon to f2
and
yeah the winning idea for black in this
position like if i just play
a waiting move with my king
he's ready to build a bridge with this
move
and then
if i wait with the king he can do this
and then after check here check here
check here check
this is a so-called bridge
which explains my last ditch effort
rook g5 trying to prevent him from
building the bridge
but then he plays a really annoying move
with g7 and he just waits
and now my my rook or king have to move
and i'm essentially in some sort of zulu
vong
um but it's going to be losing
regardless for white decide to play king
to c1 then he plays rook d4 i don't have
king c3 to attack the rook and he's
building the bridge like this
i play king c2
king e2
and yeah if i give a check he's ready to
do this this and again this is a bridge
king is sheltered pawn is queening
so i didn't resign here because i had
one last trick up my sleeve
after king c3 he plays rook f4
i play rook to b5
with a very deep idea
that after he queens
i play rook to b1
we got this position
and i said oh no my rook
although i didn't say oh no my rook but
i i said it to myself
and i tried to
hide my laughter in this position and of
course he does not take it
but he plays queen c6 or queen f3 and i
resign
um
for the the beginners watching who are
maybe confused if he were to take my
rook this would be stalemate so
had to get in at least one stalemate
trap this tournament but uh yeah it's
not going to work against a strong gm
so it's a tough game um
i have a feeling i know where things
went wrong if we go back
uh
i'll very quickly look at the engine
but
i also kind of want food so let's just
look at this moment
uh oh both moves are playable okay
uh but yeah already here it's it's
tricky i should have played rook h8
it's interesting engines giving a small
plus to light
should still be a draw though
so what was my losing move
ah rook d6 yeah
i was in time trouble
so engine says i should take
but it's super unpleasant to defend this
anyway yeah it was tough game
uh kudos to my opponents
i hope people learned a thing or two
from this fight maybe we're somewhat
entertained
so thanks for watching if you made it
this far
and now it's time for food